okay so today is january 6th it is the
first anniversary of the only important
moment in modern american history
according to the left here is the thing
the reason that the left is paying
attention to january 6th is pure
politics this is pure political theater
because politics is always politics and
it is not possible to be too cynical
about politics it really is not the big
news of the day is not january 6. the
big news of the day is that the federal
reserve officials at their meeting last
month according to the wall street
journal are now eyeing a faster
timetable for raising interest rates
this year potentially as soon as march
and democrats are panicking because when
the fed raises the interest rates yes
inflation gets curbed but also
unemployment is likely to go up because
typically when you raise the interest
rates you make it harder for people to
borrow when you make it harder for
people to borrow they cannot then spend
that money on hiring people and so
employment tends to go down and so
democrats are freaking the they're
freaking the hell out and they should be
freaking out
this is all bad policy brought about by
joe biden's interventionist take on
economics and the federal reserve
raising its rates is going to have some
pretty dire effects for the democrats
come 2022 in the midterm elections
according to the wall street journal
minutes of their december 14th to 15th
meeting released wednesday showed
officials believe that rising inflation
in a very tight labor market could call
for lifting short-term rates sooner or a
faster pace than participants had
earlier anticipated some officials also
thought the fed should start shrinking
its 8.76 trillion dollar portfolio of
bonds and other assets relatively soon
after beginning to raise the rates
investors would see the moves another
way for the fed to tighten financial
conditions to cool the economy
okay the predictable effect of this
revelation is that stocks immediately
dumped
they turned sharply lower after the
minutes were released on wednesday
afternoon the the dow jones fell 1.1
percent the nasdaq lost 3.3 percent
meanwhile government bond yields rose on
wednesday
trading in interest rate futures implied
a roughly two-thirds probability that
the fed would raise rates in march okay
so what does this mean it means that
democrats desperately desperately have
to redirect to january 6. so both kamala
harris the vice president of the united
states and joe biden spoke at the
capitol rotunda this morning they did so
because of course they have to make hay
while the sun shines january 6 being the
most important thing in history joe
biden is not great at this commonwealth
harris is just absolutely abysmal at
this so joe biden was able to sort of
cover some of his some of his tracks
kamala harris just kind of puts it all
right out there here in this very
building
a decision will be made about whether we
uphold the right to vote and ensure
free and fair elections
let's be clear
we must pass
voting rights bills that are now before
the senate
and
the american people
must also do something more
we cannot sit on the sidelines
we must unite
in defense of our democracy
here was vice president kamala harris
claiming that january 6th was just like
wait for it pearl harbor and 9 11.
certain dates echo throughout history
including dates that instantly
remind all who have lived through them
where they were
and what they were doing
when our democracy came under assault
dates that occupy
not only a place on our calendars
but a place
in our collective memory
december 7th 1941
september 11
and january 6th
2021.
uh here's joe biden talking about the
threat to democracy from which he must
save us all
i did not seek this fight
brought to this capital one year ago
today
but i will not shrink from it either
i will stand in this breach
i will defend this nation
not allow no one to place a dagger at
the throat of democracy
we will make sure the will of the people
that's heard
that the ballot prevails not violence
that authority in this nation will
always
be peacefully transferred i mean this is
joe biden's entire stick his entire
shtick is democracy was under grave
unbelievable unprecedented threat on
january 6 but he will stand in the
breach all you have to do is give him
complete ultimate power
you can't love your country only when
you win
you can't obey the law only when it's
convenient
you can't be patriotic when you embrace
and enable lies
those who storm this capital
and those who instigated and incited
and those who called on them to do so
held a dagger at the throat of america
at american democracy it's so tiresome
and so tiresome because we know the game
that he's playing right i mean the game
that he is playing right here is let me
pass the legislation i want otherwise
you are the dagger at the throat of
democracy when he compares what happened
on january 6th to the edmund pettus
bridge you know like black people being
beaten up for being black as part of a
broader jim crow effort to subvert the
rights of black people when he compares
it to when he compares it to december
7th what he's really saying is that
anybody who disagrees with his agenda is
the enemy because when he says he wants
a renaissance of democracy he does not
mean respect for elections purely and
simply
what he really means is pass my voting
rights act he means let me add 87
justices to the supreme court and kill
the filibuster and federalize election
procedure that's what he means it's a
political game and pretending that it's
not pretending that this is all just
good-hearted let's get together and be
more civil about our election that's not
what he's doing and anyone with half a
brain knows that's not what he's doing
okay the worse things get for the
democrats the more they're going to
redirect to january 6th now why
i mean this is the real question that
should be asked why so january 6 was a
bad moment in american history it was
and it was a moment in american history
what i mean by that is that president
trump spent from november 4th to january
6th telling people that he had duly won
the election and that for fraudulent
reasons joe biden was being selected as
president and then he had his legal
advisors telling people falsely that
under the electoral contact the vice
president of the united states had the
capacity to simply throw away state
certified votes that is not true donald
trump had every legal avenue available
to him to challenge election results he
did it sometimes he didn't allege half
of the stuff that he has alleged
publicly and so by the time that it came
time to certify the election which
happened in early december by the time
that happened the trump team had
basically
made no case as to why states should
throw out their own election results
that is not to deny that there is
election fraud in a country with 155
million votes there will be some
election fraud this is not to deny that
there wasn't screwing around with the
elections given the procedures of 2020.
thanks to the pandemic and thanks to
democratic opportunism there are a bunch
of absentee ballots that were being sent
out to people who did not ask for them
or you had
increased
drop in mailboxes or you had increase in
terms of the the number of people who
are voting early right all of this is
true
and it is also true that the election
was in fact rigged from the perspective
of the media silencing information
preventing true information from getting
to the public and manipulating
information that you did see right all
of that can be true and also donald
trump did not have a legal case for
overturning the election and then it's
just the simple fact of the matter if he
had a legal case for overturning the
election he would have won some cases
legally he did not win and he won one
case legally and that was quickly
overturned out of something like 80
across the country
okay and the ballot recounts that have
been done in places like georgia and in
arizona including the audit that was
done in arizona the much belly hood
maricopa county audit found that there
was not mass electoral fraud on the
scale necessary to declare that donald
trump had won the election in arizona
for example
okay so donald trump from november 4th
to january 6 was maintaining that he was
the rightfully elected president of the
united states or that the election was
totally fraudulent or that the senate
majority leader and the vice president
of the united states had the legal
capacity to simply throw out duly
certified state votes that was not true
but donald trump did not tell people to
storm the capitol building he did not he
said that people should peacefully
protest at the capitol building so a
bunch of people went over there there
was a huge rally i mean like tens of th
tens of thousands of people
the vast majority of those people went
home the vast majority of those people
did not engage in the violence of the
capitol building and then several
hundred people did engage in violence at
the capitol building something like 100
police officers were injured and some of
those people broke into the capitol
building and some of the people in the
capitol building were running around
yelling for mike pence
or assaulting police officers and some
of those people were just kind of
wandering around inside okay that is
what happened on january 6th and then
within three hours the entire place was
clear all the congress people were back
in their seats and mitch mcconnell and
mike pence were certifying the election
that's what actually happened on january
6th
okay we were all there we all remember
it it was bad it was not good
the president of the united states
waited too long to tell people to go
home but
all of that said was this a full-blown
coup no because a coup requires some
sort of institutional support that would
legitimate a failure of an effective
transition of power and people say there
was no peaceful transition of power that
is a lie there was a peaceful transition
of power the presence of a riot does not
mean that there was no peaceful
transition of power if that were the
case there was no peaceful transition of
power back in 2017 when donald trump at
his inauguration there were massive
riots outside trump's inauguration
involving the arrest over 200 people was
that a peaceful transition of power it
was because joe biden left and donald
trump took office well on january 20th
of 2021 donald trump left and joe biden
took office that is called a peaceful
transition to power was this a moment of
crisis for our democracy no it wasn't
within three hours of
idiots invading the capitol building the
election was being certified
so then why is this a moment of national
disgrace a moment of national shame and
the answer is because for the left it
must be it must be because of the left's
goal within 24 hours of this event
forget 24 hours and 24 minutes of this
event it became wildly apparent that for
the democrats and for the media this was
gold and it was gold because they got to
try and lump in everyone who voted with
trump to people who protested the
election and then lump in all those
people with the capital rioters so the
idea was that if you voted for trump or
if you voted against biden or if you
would ever consider voting for trump or
if you would ever consider voting for
any other republican you were complicit
in the actions of january 6th this
became perfectly clear when parlor was
knocked offline by amazon web services
amazon web services is a neutral service
provider the suggestion was that parlor
had been used to organize the january 6
riots and therefore parlor needed to be
dumped offline well facebook was used
much more than parlor for that they
weren't dumped offline twitter was used
twitter was not dumped offline became
very clear very quickly that major
institutions in the united states are
going to use january 6th
as the excuse and the predicate for
cracking down on political opposition
and that's what continues today
the left argument is that january 6 is
not just something that happened it's
not just a bad thing perpetrated by
people who acted criminally and are
going to jail it was not even about
donald trump saying things that were not
true it was not about any of that it was
about a full-fledged attempt by the
right wing in the united states to
subvert democracy and that can only be
stopped according to the left by
allowing them to subvert democracy
tear away at the fundamental
institutions of republicanism in this
country get rid of the senate filibuster
for example so they can pass a voting
rights act which is not really a voting
rights act it's a federalization of
elections act
complete with insanely loose election
restrictions
right this is their argument their
argument is you must give them total
power to prevent the republicans from
taking total power because after all
those evil evil republicans are seeking
to take total power
now what are they basing that on they're
basing that on the fact that there are
laws that have been passed in states
like georgia that shore up certain
election procedures and actually loosen
certain election procedures everyone who
looks at the georgia law just facially
understands this is not a device for
stealing elections in georgia anyone who
suggests to you that the georgia
election law is about republicans
stealing elections out of their mind or
lying to you
the the great election threat here does
not exist okay republicans are not
stealing elections across the country
the the left is suggesting for example
that the john lewis voting rights act be
used in order to crack down on
particularly red states when it comes to
redistricting there's only one problem
according to cook political in
republican states in which they've
engaged in redistricting this year
there really is no major shift toward
republican seats there's actually more
of a shift in democratic states with
democratic redistricting than there is
in republican states with republican
redistricting in other words this is not
a major problem
but democrats have decided it's a major
problem because they wish to use this as
the excuse to seize more power
that's what this is about this is not a
sincere effort nobody believes this is
sincerely about january 6th
if it was like which part of it would be
sincere from the left the part where
they're very upset about people
protesting elections
who's going to make that case governor
stacy abrams of georgia lost an election
by 50 000 votes and was declared in 2020
a governor of georgia by the democratic
party at their national convention
who exactly on the democratic side of
the aisle is really upset about people
who protest elections the same people
who spent four years declaring that
donald trump was only president because
of russian collusion and facebook memes
or maybe we're supposed to believe that
the democratic left is deeply deeply
upset and angry over the treatment of
police officers on january 6th i mean
hell the new york times has an entire
piece today titled capitol police bear
scars of riots
okay now i just have a question
about 100 police officers 120 police
officers were injured on january 6th
over the course of the black lives
matter riots which were predicated on a
huge lie
a much bigger lie by the way in
consequence for literally millions of
americans than the lie that president
trump openly won the 2020 election for
example the lie that america's police
are systemically racist targeting black
men and shooting them down in the
streets that's what black lives matter
was predicated upon it was a full-blown
lie promoted by every major democrat to
the point where you had the current vice
president of the united states bailing
rioters out of jail
in minnesota
in those riots over 2 000 police
officers were injured not one word from
democrats on this so are we supposed to
believe that the reason that they're
truly that this is a truly historical
event is because of this treatment of
police is that what we're meant to
believe from the media and the democrats
which part of january 6th is is the part
that they are are really they're
standing on solid ground in terms of
their own approach toward for example
elections or treatment of police or
treatment of political violence which
they winked and nodded at in some cases
openly promoted in the middle of 2020
that's why as always this is a political
game and pretending that it is anything
but a political game is being pretty
damned dishonest
the battle for the culture is heating up
we here at the daily wire are making
some big moves so be sure to like
subscribe ring that bell because you're
not going to want to miss a single
moment